hey guys welcome to the first lunch and
earn series this is a new series that
I've started to try to give you some
ideas and wisdom to help you over lunch
time and give you some resources to help
you grow your business today I'm asking
a question from one of my mastermind
group members Moishe who is questioning
whether on her YouTube channel she
should be doing a 30 day challenge now
she's regularly posting about one video
a week as one of that's going to be too
much than I jumped to doing 30 videos in
30 days and what am I feedback on what
to do so here are my quick thoughts
themes in great themes in general sorry
are great on youtube I have the ants
presso series i have my top 10 series
people like to follow along on a series
so in general i love anything testing
around themes my second point is about
quality people will tune in if it's good
right if you're doing one video week and
they love that and now you jump one
video a day they'll keep tuning in as
long as it's good you look at my channel
I started with one video a day sorry I'm
sorry one video a week and then move
that to a couple videos a week and looks
at the one video a day and then to a day
now 83 a day and people tuned in because
it's good stuff and so as long as the
quality is good every day people will
tune in and they won't unsubscribe from
your channel if it's substandard stuff
then then yeah you're going to lose
people and something to be worried about
and then my last quick thought is I'd be
concerned not as much from the audience
point of view but then also from yours
are you biting off more than you can
chew to go from a channel of posting one
video per week to then doing 30 videos
and 30 days might be too much for you
might be might be too big a challenge at
the moment to take on and you might burn
out doing it so i would suggest staying
with something smaller do a seven day
challenge you attend a challenge and see
see like see if you love it see if you
want to keep doing this because you may
get in three days into it and feel like
you know what i'm not i'm not feeling it
I mean you've committed the 30 days and
you have 27 more days of agony to finish
that off where
you did something smaller like a seven
day challenge you can see if you like it
gauge the results see if your audience
is like it in there getting involved in
it and see if it's something that you
want to continue doing all of the main
all of the main things that I have on my
channel are a result of a selfish
intention for me because I want to do it
right I mean I love it's also helping
you guys and I love that but I feel like
I need like an espresso is a morning
shot because i want that every morning
when i start my day the top 10 rules i
find inspiration for other people's
that's why i'm doing it and I'm glad you
guys made sure along that journey with
me and so that would be my advice start
with themes I love the theme idea make
sure that every video is super high
quality so you don't lose people and get
people coming back and then make sure
you're not biting off more than you can
chew and i would start as a smaller test
just to make sure that your audience is
liking it and more importantly you're
liking it and you want to continue so
thank you guys so much for watching I
will see you soon continue to believe
and have an amazing rest of your day